in this video we'll talk about the
conditional specification this is a very
important topic to understand
developmental biology conditional
specification is the process by which
cells achieve their respective Fate by
interacting with other cells in the
vicinity that means interaction matters
so here is a red cell in an embryo
what this red cell would eventually
become is dependent on how it interacts
with its neighbor moral of the story
neighbors matter
so question is how does neighboring
cells influence the fat specification of
this particular cell it turns out there
are many ways of influencing the Fate
specification
one way of doing that is cell to cell
contact and this is known as just a
cream signaling
there could be also secreted signals
such as paracrine signaling factors that
is interpreted by this red cell and that
governs the Fate specification
now
from these modes there could be also
physical properties
there could be also mechanical stress
rigidity of the extracellular
environment that all can actually govern
the Fate specification
now this kind of conditional fate
specification was nicely demonstrated in
zebrafish embryo with a elegant
transplantation experiment in early
1970s
so look at the control situation this
control
embryo would eventually give rise to a
particular a zebrafish larvae now any
cell which is present in the dorsal part
that means in this blue region would
eventually become cells of the back
and that's pretty much expected
and any cells that are present in the
yellow region would eventually become
the cells of the belly or the lower
region ventral region
now scientists have created a
transplantation experiment where they
have taken a cell from the back and put
it in the belly region
and then they ask what happens to these
cells in the belly region do they retain
a fate of back cells or they eventually
become belly cells and the answer is
they eventually become belly-like tissue
that means they no longer retain the
Fate that they were originally supposed
to give rise to and the cells of the
belly region influenced the fate of this
transplanted cells
that means how cell interacts with its
neighbors is really important for its
fate choice and this experiment proves
that another way of proving that is
ablating a selective region of the
embryo so using glass needles some of
the cells were removed from a blastula
and eventually it was noticed that it
didn't affect the embryonic development
the larvae actually matures normally
that tells us that if cells are removed
from the embryo the remaining cell can
regulate and compensate for that missing
part
it again tells us that how cells are
interacting with one another matters for
the sulfate specification
now it was not really accepted by the
scientific community that this kind of
conditional specification can occur
because they had a deep rooted idea of
autonomous specification in their mind
in fact there was a scientist who tried
to prove that autonomous specification
is the key thing and conditional
specification doesn't occur so let's see
what experiment he has done so he has
taken uh frog eggs at a two cell stage
he used a hot noodle needle to ablate
one cell of this two cell stage
eventually these two cell stage embryo
give rise to a blastula whose half
tissue were dead and half tissue were
living
and ultimately it give rise to half of
the embryo so this kind of experiment
tells us or actually depicts that okay
the information of one half of the
embryo was embedded in one half of that
two cell stage cells
but this idea was actually challenged by
another elegant experiment this
experiment was done by Wilhelm rocks and
also Wiseman
another experiment was done by their
colleagues they have taken sea urchin
eggs at a four cell stage
they have dissociated these cells but
before let me tell you that this four
cell stage eventually would give rise to
uh plutus larva of the sea urchin now
these four cell stage can be dissociated
with the help of vigorous shaking and
each of these blastomeres can be
separated
and they ask what happens if we separate
the blastomeres what type of cells do
they give rise to
to their surprise they noticed each of
these blastomeres give rise to an entire
plutus larva and this result was very
surprising
let me tell you why it is surprising Let
me refresh your idea about autonomous
specification autonomous specification
tells us that okay what the cell has to
become is deeply encoded within the cell
and the drives comes from inside this
red cell would eventually give rise to
this kind of ciliated red cells and the
Red Cell nose is knows this from the
beginning because if you take it out and
put it in a isolation in a Petri dish it
would eventually become the same type of
cells this was the idea about autonomous
specification indeed it was true for
several organisms but in case of this
plutus larva
if autonomous specification is true then
each of these blastomere would have the
pre-loaded
information to give rise to different
location of the embryo it's like
one-on-one mapping of different parts of
the embryo encoded by different cell
types in this four cell stage
So based on these conceptualization the
expectation of the experiment was
that okay when we dissociate these cells
each of these cells should give rise to
different larval body parts
if the information was pre-loaded and
pre-encoded into these cells
but let me tell you this was not the
observation the observation was very
different from the expectation
instead of giving rise to individual
body parts
these dissociated cell gave rise to
entire putius larva this was a reality
so what really happened
so once the cells are actually in an
intact embryo format at that point of
time cells are talking to each other
continuously they are interacting with
each other and this kind of context give
them an idea to become certain different
cell populations in the entire larva
now once the cells are dissociated
then the context would be lost now let
me tell you that in an intact situation
each of these blastomeres doesn't encode
the information to become the entire
larva because there is always a
crosstalk happening between all of them
and that prevents each of the blastomere
to become each complete embryo and in an
in-depth situation each blastomers are
talking to another blastomere to become
one particular larval part so this
talking to each other is really
important context and that context is
lost when the cells are dissociated and
at that point of time each of these
blastomeres decide to give rise to the
entire organism instead of a dedicated
body part that tells us that context and
interaction within the cell types are
really important for the Fate
specification
now we know that in vertebrate situation
and many other organisms use this kind
of contextual or context dependent
specification or conditional
specification let me give you another
example let's say there are some cells
which are specified specified to become
muscle if you keep them in isolation
they would eventually become muscle if
you keep them some if you keep some
cells which are destined to become
neuron they would eventually become
neuron no harm in that
but if you put some cells which are
about to become muscle in a near
vicinity of several neurons there are
crosstalk between these cell types now
the influence of neurons make these
would be muscle cells into a another
neuron that means how these cells
interact with the environment interact
with the neighbors are really important
moral of the story story is cell
commitment is still liable and during
specification external influences matter
and that's the whole concept of
conditional specification I hope this
video was useful if you like this video
give it a good thumbs up you can find
more notes and flashcards in my Facebook
page and Instagram links are provided in
the description you can support our
Channel using super thanks you can pay
via paytm PayPal or UPI see you in next
video